[Music]
[Applause]
i'm your host olympic gold medalist and
nobel peace prize winner amber ruffin
now are those things technically true no
but if i repeat them enough on
television you might just start to think
they are because the media can shape our
perceptions of society in ways we don't
even realize let me explain in a segment
called how did we get here
[Music]
let's talk about advertisements over the
years ads have sold us a lot of really
bad products like this actual real life
ad saying that people who are tired at
work should consider cocaine
cocaine nature's way of saying earn more
money
of course we all know that that's not
true a more realistic slogan would be
cocaine nature's way of saying i work at
a hedge fund and i'm about to tell you
my idea for a screenplay
or maybe just cocaine
whether we like it or not ads can make a
real difference so tonight we're going
to talk about what might be the most
effective and long-running ad campaign
of all time
these ads aren't running between the tv
shows they are the tv shows and the
product they're selling is the american
police officer
for most americans almost everything we
know about the police comes from the
media after all most americans have
never been arrested and in a given year
the vast majority don't have contact
with police at all in 2016 for example
only 24 of residents experienced contact
with police cops are just one of those
things you see a lot more of on tv than
in real life like simultaneous orgasms
or sheldons
i don't know a single sheldon but
they're on tv everywhere
now for the past 60 years there's been
an organized plan to build up the
reputation of the police and
do it
using the thing americans love most
sitting in front of the tv it's called
propaganda
and to understand where it comes from
let's go all the way back to the 1950s
to a show called dragnet
i just want to say that dragnet would be
an amazing name for a tv show about four
hackers who are also drag queens their
names would be
lotta ram megahertz
debug and of course their leader auntie
virus
call me
nbc
anyway
the actual dragnet show was a show about
the police and in order to make it more
realistic the creator made a deal with
the lapd to get inside information but
the police got something much better in
return because they made a deal that all
scripts had to be formally approved by
the lapd's public information division
before filming began in other words the
police got to decide how the police were
portrayed on tv which is insanely biased
it's like having rich people with
attachment issues give notes on
succession
the results of this deal with the lapd
meant that during an era when 50 los
angeles police officers brutally beat
seven young men in their custody on
christmas dragnet instead showed a group
of upstanding cops doing their darndest
to solve crimes propaganda and americans
bought it in fact it worked so well that
the media has done it over and over
since dragnet became the template for
every cop show you have ever seen from
law and order to nypd blue from ncis to
sister cops
okay i made that last one up but it's a
great idea and my sister lacey and i
would be happy to co-star call me nbc
propaganda has single-handedly created
the legend of the hero police officer
it's also perpetuated other myths that
still harm us to this day like that
crime is rising constantly or that
policing is one of the most dangerous
jobs or that black people are criminals
so let's start with the first myth that
crime in america is rampant according to
gallup polls for the past 20 years more
than half of americans believed crime is
worse than the year before yet here's
what the actual crime rate has been
doing
that's right crime has been decreasing
consistently the only thing falling more
steadily is president biden
[Laughter]
oh god
so
why do we
oh so why do we think crime is getting
worse well according to one study
people's perceptions of the crime rate
actually rise and follow along with tb
violence in other words people think
crime is bad because it's bad on tv it's
the same reason that after watching the
great british bake off i think i can
make a chocolate souffle because the
stupid lying tv made it look true now
let's look at the second myth that
policing is one of america's most
dangerous jobs now i want to be careful
on this one because being a police
officer is a dangerous job and aside
from almost spraining an ankle during a
song parody my job isn't very risky so i
don't want to discount the work that
they do but according to data from the
bureau of labor statistics being a
police officer is actually far less
dangerous than other jobs like being a
garbage collector or being a delivery
driver that's right cops actually have
fewer on-the-job fatalities than the guy
who brings you those chicken tenders you
ordered when you were drunk and then
when he arrives reminds you that you
order them
and it's important to get a realistic
idea of the dangers of policing because
one of the major reasons why we can't
reform the way cops are trained is
because people who watch police shows
think cops get into a karate fight three
times a week and even worse the
propaganda may have convinced the police
themselves that they are in constant
danger which could be why police
officers killed more people running away
from them over the past five years than
the total number of cops shot and killed
on duty
that might also be why since 2015 police
officers shot and killed three times
more black people than cops were shot
and killed by anybody
being a police officer is a dangerous
job but what might even be more
dangerous is being a black person who
runs into one and that brings us to our
final propaganda myth that black people
are criminals how does tv normalize
disproportionately killing black people
by teaching the public that they deserve
it for example in real life black people
are 35 percent of gang members but in tv
and film we play 64 percent of all gang
members and when a character is listed
as a thug it's played by a black actor
66 of the time now think about that if
every time you see a criminal on tv as a
black person you're going to start to
think there's a correlation in the same
way that if every time i see a skin care
commercial j lo was in it i'm going to
start thinking it's normal to look like
this at 52. it's not
she's superhuman she shouldn't look like
that basically we've been fed an ad
campaign that teaches us that police
officers are heroes putting themselves
in grave danger to save us from a
crime-ridden country full of black
criminals and that's [ __ ] so if we
want to make it better we are going to
have to fight against the coppa anna and
start working with the truth
take it from me heisman trophy winner
and current prime minister of iceland
amber ruffin this has been how did we
get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you